[Music]
you know the moon right the big space
rock humans landed on for the first time
fifty years ago
well astronauts left a lot of stuff
behind their stuff like use scientific
equipment clothing food wrappers and
well their poop across all six moon
landings Apollo astronauts left 96 bags
of human waste on the moon we're talking
poop pee vomit it was left behind a safe
wait for the return trip stuffed in big
trash baggies like this one dropped from
Apollo 11 and inside those bags is a big
unanswered question it's a scientific
mystery that I want answered
is there anything alive in that moon poo
I know I know this sounds ridiculous but
the answer might help us understand how
life started on earth and it can help us
understand our potential to contaminate
other worlds like Mars with our literal
[ __ ] and the answer is not too far away
is lying in wait nearly 240,000 miles
away on the moon right here that was
this really isn't ask a little what I'm
saying is we got to go back for that
[ __ ] human feces can be disgusting sure
this is not really displayed up but it's
also teeming with life
around half of its mass is made up of
bacteria representing some of the
thousand plus species of microbes that
live in our guts with the moon landings
we took microbial life on Earth to the
most extreme environment has ever been
in and we don't know if it can survive
there and all the ways earth is so
hospitable to life the moon is not does
not have a protected magnetic field to
deflect the most powerful and damaging
cosmic radiation doesn't have an ozone
layer to absorb the sun's ultraviolet
rays it doesn't have an atmosphere and
the moon is subjected to wild
temperature swings over day and night a
lot would have to go right for the
microbes to still be alive there or at
least revival from a dormant state but
there are some scientists who want to go
back and check because there are two
really fascinating things that we can
learn from this poop
the first has to do with a planet
millions of miles away from the moon
Mars for decades scientists have
wondered if there's life on Mars and the
gang closer to figuring it out Mars is a
thin atmosphere evidence of flowing
water and a more hospitable environment
than the moon
if microbes couldn't survive on the moon
they're even more likely to survive on
Mars so what happens if humans go to
Mars and leave their poop there and the
microbes in it start to spread it'll be
hard to tell what life we find there is
Martian and what life we brought with us
if we accidentally contaminate the
planet with our poop there's also a
bigger question there's a hypothesis
about how life started on earth that
didn't actually start an earth at all
that some asteroid or comet containing
some microbes crash-landed here and
seeded life on the planet
finding living things in moon poop could
support that hypothesis because if
microbial life can survive on the moon
it can survive on an asteroid - and if
the hypothesis is true it can mean life
travels across the universe jumping from
planet to planet from asteroid
collisions here's a Wilder thought let's
say an asteroid comes hurtling by slams
into the moon and projects the Apollo
mission moon poop into the deep reaches
of space could that seed life in the
broader universe maybe so how do we
figure out the answer to these great
mysteries easy you go back
[Music]
that's gonna take a lot of work and
research and diving into internet click
holes bad security for anything you're
doing including a project to go back to
the moon can ruin everything
enter - lame - lame is the one tool you
need to stay safe online it helps keep
you safe online and protects your most
sensitive information and will even let
you know you've been the victim of a
hack - Lang can utter generate and
autofill super strong passwords on all
websites where you have accounts it
works on any browser and any device and
syncs your data instantly between all of
them and it even includes a
multi-country VPM so you can stay safe
and browse privately on any device so go
to - lang comm slash box to get a 30-day
free trial of - lien preview and use the
promo code box to get 10% off - lean
premium - lang doesn't directly impact
our editorial but their support makes
videos like this possible so click the
link in the description to check them
out
[Music]